caed what's goody how bre the verse
welcome back to Hot Breath the show
where you learn comedy from the pros I
am your host comedian Joel buers and
after interviewing over 400 comedians on
this show we are doing our first ever
comedian Round Table live from Toronto
in celebration of Just for Laughs
Festival the vision with this show is to
start doing this in front of live
audiences at Comedy Festival so if you
think that's a dope idea a comment on
this video with what festivals you want
to see hot breath at and we going to
pull up but I am so excited for the
comics and people that pulled up today
so let's introduce them one at a time
starting to my right here hot breath
Alum Ian Edwards what's goody fam what's
up Ian Edwards uh as he said comic good
to be here second time on the
podcast and uh I'm just gonna throw to
the homie right here yeah yeah throw it
Arian TBO I'm the programming manager at
just just for last but I got my big
break in comedy being a producer of
lowkey comedy show with my friend Paul
here oh
hi lowy comedy show the co-creator
co-created with Matt R during the
pandemic also I got my comedy special
shooting it in two weeks in Detroit
October 13th and 14th it's called
Detroit Player Detroit House of Comedy
and I'm going to drop it sometime in
December this is in four weeks right it
wait what happened again no go
ahead
what's up y'all I'm Eva alexopoulos
creator of the kickback and this is what
my third time on the podcast third time
on podcast happy to be back so we're
yeah we're just going to talk comedy
this is going to be like we're talking a
lot of good comedy game and the first
thing that was top of mind for me with
having people in front of the scenes and
behind the scenes here is like the
current state of Comedy it's an
interesting time right now comedy's
booming bigger than ever there's more
Arena acts than ever but there's also
open micers shooting crowdwork clips
with red cams in front of four people
and going viral and then selling out
clubs so it's an interesting time in
comedy and a lot of you have experience
that a little longer than others but I'd
be interested to hear your opinions on
the current state of comedy and maybe
where you think it's headed uh I'm not
mad at none of it you know what I mean
like somebody's gonna you know take the
initiative to go out there and shoot
some [__] and you know they're still
going to have to be funny or learn how
to be funny at some point so it has to
balance itself out
but sometimes you can't rely on the
honesty of the comedy industry to put
people where they need to be so and with
the world's Chang man you just can't be
like in a oldfashioned like you didn't
wait to do this podcast you 400 comics
in you didn't like wait for somebody to
like give you the stamp of approval to
do this so I'm like [__] it you like it
yeah for it
yeah man some like sink or swim
mentality you know like if you don't do
it on your own then you're just going to
get washed so it's like do it on your
own it's like yeah if you're shooting a
crowd word clip and it's funny and
people are paying tickets to see you and
you suck that's okay too you know what
I'm saying like not like the book
doesn't have to end so prematurely you
know maybe for some people after that
happens they quit
but
good it's like the last round table
podcast you
do he goes back to an
individual no man but I think it's cool
man it's fun to experiment is throw
paint on the canvas you know like I
never understood why paintings that just
have random paint blobs are worth so
much money but then I'm starting to like
understand how it could be worth money
you know yeah that's a good way like
this like those abstract paintings of
some of these like early sets from
people yeah it's like you know it's like
when you when you're a director and
you're making a movie it's like you have
to make a good movie the first time out
but with comedy you could just show
people the process and then you can have
a terrible clip and then five years
later have a great clip and people can
see the growth so
yeahh I always find a lot of it also has
to do with like ego and what you're
willing to do like the world is always
going to change marketing and business
is always going to keep evolving and i'
I've seen a lot of the people that I
know that kind of struggle with the
whole like posting Clips thing or I want
to keep this joke a secret or someone's
going to steal it or it's going to be
retired it's like well there's someone
younger than you less experienced than
you that is posting at triple the rate
and just based on the algorithm it's
getting picked up so you can jump on the
bandwagon or you cannot jump on the
bandwagon but I don't know I I kind of
agree with you and I don't think there's
an issue with it at all I just think
it's more of a you thing like if you're
feeling a type of way about it you
should probably start posting and that's
kind of that's kind of how I see it yeah
what about from the industry perspective
because I mean there's like a lot of
young Comics who
may not have the time to back up a viral
clip but where what's the balance for
someone that like isn't part of a big
Festival like JFL well I think to them
to to Ian's point we're in an
interesting time because you know
there's never been more ways to put
yourself on the map but at the same time
it's really overwhelming because if you
it feels like you're never doing enough
you know and then like you said someone
can put up a clip and it flops and then
they think oh I'm not a good comic it
didn't work um but actually like really
funny and they do a great job and then
other Comics are just really good at
picking up the algorithm and they're
also funny but it's just like a
different mindset so for us as a
festival it's making sure that we work
with people who like do have a large
audience but also we're like hey trust
our insight and like we want to
introduce you to some people that are
really really funny and I still think
that's super valuable and a lot of
comics I feel like they see their Clips
compare it to someone else and then they
just kind of say oh no like but I think
it's there's so much more to it and like
you said like someone can be like a
really Niche kind of comedy and do
really well in a festival and whatnot so
I think it's it's a really interesting
time that we're in but also it is a lot
of pressure for for Comics whatnot so
being able to work within a festival
capacity it makes space like for
everybody so I think that's do you think
like as a what it's just amazing how her
French accent just went
away she saw her outside how the [__]
did she do that when I met her
before then on the show it was beginning
of the
podcast how do you cuz I can't see my
name wrong it's you want me to see AR
you want me to see
C first of all it was a compliment I
said it's amazing I don't know if they
compliment people in
Montreal I was it's amazing how French
accent went away compared to how you
introduce yourself I can't do [__] so
yeah I mean she challenged me to a duel
earlier she take off her glove and slap
you with
it impressive impressive thank you
respect respect
respect see she has a white voice as
well can we all have that what what is
wait what's the what's the word for that
uh in French yeah I can't even find the
word in
English yeah [__] it [__] it let's keep
going keep going
that's so funny but do you guys think
there's young like when should Comics
start posting like is it ever too soon
do you think they should like get at
least like a few years in and get
proficient or like it's just wild west I
mean they're not going to listen anyway
yes okay it's like you could say any
advice and people are be like n I'm just
going to do my thing so it's just like
you know like I I personally like I'm at
the point in my career where I don't
want to put out some things unless
they're like heaters CU I put out things
that people did like and people have
commented on and said that they really
appreciate it and shared and these are
people that I respect their taste so I'm
like cool well I want to put out more
good stuff I'm not going to upload a
Vine I did a few years ago and be like
hey here's this video just to post but
there's also people that are about uh
quantity and they're posting every day
and some things like not as hilarious as
others but they're like bro this is my
canvas it's fine I'll throw a dud out
there every now and then and it's it's
okay and then sometimes these Duds blow
up and they may not speak for their sens
so it's like you know I think people
should just post whenever they feel like
it just let the algorithm tell that it
sucks this is what I learned from all my
years of experienc in comedy that I
can't call it like I've given some of
the best comics in comedy some of the
biggest Comics the worst
advice and if they had listened to me if
Kevin Hart had listened to me years ago
you'd have never heard of
Kevin and that's and I I don't know
that's and I told him the opposite of
exactly what he did serious and he's I'm
dead up bro what' you tell him because
he had a TV show I wrote on it he was a
great when he used to do auditions he
used to run them by me and I was like
this guy is going to book a bunch of
auditions but he wanted to go on the
road and make less money to build up his
Road career and I was like why would you
want to go out of town where you could
stay in town you'll probably get on
another TV show and once you get on the
TV show you'll blow up that way but he
didn't want to do that he went on the
Road he ended up on the Shaq allar
Comedy Jam and the clip that he did on
that blew up and he blew up on the road
and then he got the more TVs and movies
so it's like you you can't listen to
me he's like I like to not thank exactly
so it's like when Paul's like just post
whenever you know and they're not going
to listen anyway just do you yeah you
know mhm also like so before I was in
comedy I worked in marketing for 10
years and I had an influencer agency
genes so a lot of comics like ask me
what works what should I be posting what
should I be doing and I think a lot of
people who never triy to build the
following like agents managers or even
Bookers will be like just post and if
you've never done it you have no idea
what you're talking about so that's
that's it's really hard like it's a
full-time job so I always tell Comics
like figure out what's the one way of
doing it that feels natural to you that
doesn't feel like something you dread so
sometimes it's Tweeting or Xing or
whatever it's called now but like if
you're a good a writer and that's how
you like to do your thing and you want
to post that then that could be good if
it's more podcast clip that you're
comfortable if you're the kind of guy
who wakes up and he's like hey guys
welcome to my channel and that makes you
comfortable but find a thing that you're
comfortable doing that you feel like you
can do consistently without hating your
life completely and actually enjoy
yourself and that's going to be the one
for you versus always comparing yourself
to what everybody else is doing like I
think with lowy and with yours you
figured out okay like I really like
filming bits of my comedy and posting
versus someone else going to be in his
car every morning and say this is my
thought of the day and that's going to
be his thing you know so I think it's
it's really about figuring out what
you're comfortable doing and sticking to
that but it could be a lot when people
are giving you the advice to post post
post and if look if they've never tried
in any way to build a social media
following like don't listen to that I
would say you know smart and do
something that like to your point if if
you're not some somebody who is someone
who holds the camera up is like hey
what's up and you know in your heart
that's not you like your audience is
going to sense it as well they're going
to kind of feel it through the camera so
[__] post with your back to the camera
that's what
you like hey y'all how y'all doing you
know this me welcome back welcome backe
do whatever let point it at the sky
juice you know just do whatever makes
you feel comfortable somebody else might
be able to identify with it you know
yeah or as a team cuz like you and and
Paul have done like skits together and
things so maybe not like a solo hustle
on this also combin with somebody collab
that's the word right collab collab he
showing his age there collab it used to
combine baby back in my
day yes so there is an interesting part
of like developing as a comun but also
just trying to develop a following and
like trying to stay relevant and like be
good at comedy but then also this whole
other side of the game we're trying to
fuse the two well like the same way
somebody can blow up that way it's also
extra work so you have to give the
person who's posting credit for extra
work like when I started there was no
social media so you just had you if you
had time you just worked on your standup
now you have to work on both and not
just work on it like write the offstage
[__] that you're going to post edit it
shoot it and post it and then work on
your standard so some people might get
upset that some people are blowing up
but they also are doing the extra work
to blow up so it's not just like this
free pass online pass everybody it's not
the the VIP pass at Disneyland you're
getting to get on just get to the front
of the line you're still you're still
doing something yeah I think yeah
especially with like how Matt R is blown
up I feel like some people are like oh
yeah he's been grinding at this for over
10 years he's earned all of this and
other people are like oh he has a super
strong jawline and that's why he like
blew up you know both things are true
yeah both can exist it is a nice jawline
like why waste it being a a non-comic
yeah you know what I'm saying you just
found the right angle of the clip at one
point where you both
the but I know Paul you like started
with him so like what what have you what
has it been like and he's producing your
new special that you're filming in
October so like what has it been like
seeing that rise what have you like
learned from seeing in that from
beginning um hard work pays off really I
mean cuz like for so long like and Ian
knows us too like you know Ian was doing
a lot of our shows and when we started
during the pandemic and you know we
would sell out these shows and I guess
it was a part of us that felt like all
right we're the only show in town in the
entertainment capital of the world yeah
no one else is doing shows live shows
and then more shows started to like
Blossom from that and you know people
would always give us that credit like
y'all were the first ones to do a live
show in LA and it's like when no one was
doing and [__] we felt like the score
was z0 finally because it it was always
like the St odds were stacked against us
and it's like when everything was a
clean slate it's like it basically
became a push-up contest it's like let's
see who could do the most push-ups and
that person's going to win and we were
always like waiting for that because
like we were always behind in the race
because it was just at least that's what
it felt like in a lot of ways where it's
like a lot of the clubs didn't really
show us a whole lot of love you know
Matt and I were also producing our own
shows and doing our own thing like we
weren't like welcomed into the industry
like people are like Matt your
jaw yeah he didn't just get the jawline
he's been he he been had a jaw he was
still not [__] he been broke with that
jawline for a minute so yeah he broke
with the jaw Ramen with that jaw he
didn't get a a jaw
job over the pandemic and just pop out
of noise it's like you know what's going
to help the
show Jaws are side that's what people
should do now instead of getting the new
nose like why is nose jobs more popular
than Jo jobs I don't know but he's about
to start a trend spell some gacha
there's a lot of what's GHA it's the
thing you women you or men used to but
you it's like a daily exercise face
roller snatched oh we're come become
snatched that's hilarious Comics now are
all fine as hell so where are you from
that's cool right life GHA so fun we
selling merch after the show was yeah
that's what Matt R should be selling
after the show but it was wild cuz it
was just like you know like what I
always tell Matt I'm like people are
like oh this guy blew up out of nowhere
and it's like man he been cute he been
all the things that have the cache that
make Matt like it's a cocktail of things
it's funny he's impeccable on his feet
he's very witty and he's attractive and
he worked hard and he already had
credits before and he he why do you
sound like his black
girlfriend and did
that y why am I talking like I
[Laughter]
got start with the smallest
finger you know and it's like so it's
honestly it's really cool to see because
it I I I said this in this interview we
did it it feels like we were gas lit for
a while you know where it was just like
we were working so hard and like people
just like walk past us after shows or
like when we did our first show which is
unrealistic we sort of expected we're
like man HBO B give us a deal we did the
first attempt to do this thing ain't no
one do this it's like let's wait for
this check you know and it's just like
and then nothing happens and then it's
just like and we were comfortable like
we're just going to keep going until
something happens and then it happened
yeah you know lowkey and now it's at JFL
and your show Kickbacks at JFL we had it
this summer it was awesome that's so
cool it's weird it's kind of like
parallel universes Aran was like at the
center of it this entire time yeah yeah
she we met because she came to my show
like 2 years ago in April yeah it was
really cool cuz I left when I left
Montreal the comedy scene in Montreal
wasn't it it was a rough time like there
was a few clubs but I don't think there
were as many comedy fans so it was hard
to get fans into the shows and basically
I went to LA and then I met Paul and
then we started producing these shows at
the comedy store and then I had to to
come back to Montreal uh and then I had
the opportunity to go to a kickback and
it was in this Abandoned movie theater
and how many people did you have in
there like 500 500 and she had like a DJ
and people were
smoking well so like when's a ComEd
going to
start shut down but but it was it was so
what I love like what I love about
Montreal I often find I don't see in our
Just for Laughs or touristy event and
things like that because it's so unique
to our DNA that it's really hard to get
it outside and when I went to the
kickback I was like oh this is what
Montreal represents to me like the
lineup was really fun Eva was such a
wonderful host like it was such a cool
show and and it inspired me too like I
came back and I spoke to Evan I came
back with and I was like saying oh this
is the kind of stuff they're doing you
know of course we he already had a a
beat maker but then we kept adding
things to make sure that people would
like come to the show but also like talk
about it and and and it was really
interesting to just have these
brainstorming sessions that would kind
of make the shows work together and then
Eva ended up coming to when we first
booked low key at the just for last
Festival I was a producer and Eva opened
the show so it was like all the world
like colliding and her people who love
the kickback also love low key it's it's
a very different show but it like kind
of Hit the spots so yeah it all kind of
came together now we're all here which
is kind of crazy when you think about it
because like everything that's good
starts from just wanting to do something
good like you guys wanted to build
something for the community and give
people a space Montreal didn't really
have an English Community scene period
we have a very strong French scene why
is it let's tell us tell us about
the I got it what's the tea we have we
have very strong two cultures in our
city right we have the French and then
we have the English and on the French
side naturally the government is going
to push a lot of the French art so on
the French scene you can make a lot of
money there's a ton of Club Productions
we have our own star system in Quebec
which is really interesting where like a
lot of French Canadians only consume
French Canadian content so like snobs
influencers in Quebec make more money
than influencers in LA because there's
like 10 of them who get all the
contracts versus so many of them and the
same thing happens in in comedy where
people can make a really really good
living when they're just like one year
two year into comedy it's really and and
the English side like you have to have a
lot of grit you have to if you want
opportunities in English you have to
create it yourself and uh my boyfriend
and I at the time it was like right
before things got really messy in Canada
like we were still allowed M with the
pandemic or between you and him now it's
always what kind of
messine his Pastor father's watching
another YouTube podcast of mine I'm
going to get in trouble
again um but you know we were kind of
like sitting around there's a lot of
open mics and there's a lot of this but
there's also kind of a weird system
where it's like if you don't do a Monday
then you're not going to get a Tuesday
and if you and there's only three little
clubs in the city on the English side so
we were like well you know what if we
just meshed music and comedy together
which is Montreal is the Festival City
it's there's a different Festival every
week happening there so we just wanted
to kind of create a space where people
can chill because it's hard enough to
get any fandom on the English side in
Montreal like it's hard for people to
really love somebody and like freak out
unless it's Drake and that's Toronto but
we don't really have that
so we wanted to kind of create something
a little different where it was a Vibe
and you were coming from the vibe and
you can kind of trust that we'd
introduce you to some good people but we
never thought it would blow up the way
it did it was supposed to be like a
one-off so you you've helped several
shows get involved in Just for Laugh
like what do you look for with a
comedian or a show or like this how
could we get this at Just for Laughs you
know like what what can a comedian do to
like get more involved in like festivals
in general um don't worry I got this
uh he's going to bring up politics again
like well you're too white Joel that's
the problem we need diversity yeah well
you know what's interesting because
we're talking about the clips earlier
and you know I have like I'm a big
comedy fan I've been a comedy fan for
like the last 20 years like I'll listen
to different interviews I just like love
it but then I try to always see it from
a perspective of like people who like
watch Comedy sometimes and like who come
to the festival and kind of get in their
brain and often like my friends I'm like
what tickets are you interested what do
you buy and we're talking about Clips
earlier it's interesting how the
algorithm now people don't decide with
their own brain what they like they they
see a lot of likes and love and they
decide this is popular therefore I like
like I don't think it's on purpose but
there's definitely something there in
your subconscious so I think as someone
who works for the festival my goal and I
tell my friends I'm like go see some
other shows like we have the off JFL
Festival that's like we want to
introduce you to something cool and also
that that that versus going to a stadium
and seeing a show which is cool going to
like a smaller venue that's intimate and
you get to see some riffing and
something you get to experience
something really unique that you won't
experience elsewhere so I'd say my focus
has really been on trying to find these
shows or trying to see okay do we need
to produce shows like this like what I
thought was so special about low key is
that when I start first got to La I
would just go to comedy shows all the
time like I was traveling alone for like
two years and I thought it was the best
way that you could go somewhere and kind
of be comfortable and get to know the
city and you know if you're always going
to shows you see a lot of the comics do
the same sets often but then you go to a
show like low key and you get to see
them in a whole different Universe you
know and even at the festival here like
Gavin Matt's a great example of like
really great writer great set solo show
and then he comes on lowkey and we just
saw a whole other side of his
personality and you just feel like
you're making it you're in experiencing
something really special but also making
an intimate connection with that
comedian so I guess to answer your
question like I I look for things that I
want the fans to discover but that also
are going to do well within the festival
large picture that we have a little bit
of everything and uh yeah hope that
answers the question so something that's
interesting and unique but that can also
sell tickets exactly no exactly well
yeah yeah so it could be either
something that that's like low key that
we utilize who already is in the city
and then trying to put them in a
different context um or something that
feels really special unique that we know
how we're going to sell it to to people
because of course we want them to be
interested but sometimes you have to for
instance in Montreal we had this show
called stamp toown that after the first
night everybody came and they they told
everybody about it and then it kept
feeling more and more every night but
the first night no one had ever heard
about it like no one really get like not
that they didn't care but they weren't
like oh I got to go see this show but
then from the word of MTH it really
built and and that's the magic I think
of the festival really oh beautiful man
you speak Show Business really well no
wonder you you run the Festival
yeah well well you know what's funny to
think about like like the show hot ones
yeah it's such a unique format and it's
so simple it's like you're eating wings
and you're being interviewed and it's
like part of the cache is like as it
goes on you want to see how hot it gets
and it will keep people watching as an
example and like I I think that's like
such a simple cool format so it's like I
think there's more formats to be
discovered but it's like and I think
it's fine with trial and error like I
went to one show and they were like
guess what drug they're on and then the
comic do stand up and they're like all
right after they said so so what do you
guys what do you guys think is happening
go like is he is he is he drunk they're
like yeah he's drunk and then they're
like all right let's go to the next
comedian I kind of find that really
funny is this I'm like there's something
there yeah you know what I mean so it's
just like you know and I'm not saying
like ideas are like you know I wouldn't
discourage it but it's like I think the
germ of like people want to create more
unique shows that's happening now you
like a lot of people trying to create
their own unique experience where it's
like incorporating comedy and insert
another thing yeah you know interview
insert another thing so it's like this
hybrid style and I think people want to
see that now and I think with the rise
of the internet people want to see like
a mixture of things it's like a it's
like a idea cocktail yeah man I'm
learning so much do you do you guys
think that might be
because um we're just always being
targeted with content constantly
constantly constantly or different types
of comment shows that now people are
kind of craving novelty and that's
what's pushing people to create these
different types of Comedy experiences um
well I think you know like think of like
back in the days like we'd all like
watch the same show at the same time
like who's the star now that's Kevin
Hart he was on TV like I think now
there's a very widespread of Interest so
that that's why it is a little harder to
because you're you're trying okay what
are people excited about and people who
are excited about like reaton would they
be interested in comedy and then you you
try to see where that all comes together
because I think now people have such a
wide span of different interests that
they have so it's like yeah I think that
that's what makes it really interesting
because now you can create some really
Niche shows that appeal to a small
community but do extremely well within
this like Patty Harrison we had at the
Festival this year is like a really good
example of something that's really out
there before we'd have like we' call
like alternative comedy that doesn't
really exist anymore like it's really
you know whatever you want to be doing
but there's people that are able to
create something that's very unique to
them and then do really well where I
think that before it would have been a
lot harder if it's not something that
everybody understands you know do you
guys think it has to do something with
like a sales point it's like a
differentiator in terms of like when
you're producing a show for the first
time in a city that's as diluted as New
York or La do you feel like with lowkey
what made you guys bring in the truck
and do you think that the truck is what
really made a difference in the
experience of the audience when they
came in yeah for for sure I mean I think
it was definitely a huge part of the
identity of the show because it created
this like feel and Vibe where it's like
three people sitting on a truck having a
conversation and it's hilarious it also
has this homey feel to it so I think
that was our you know that was our
chicken wing yeah interesting ours was
the free shot yeah it was a free shot
and for some reason that was enough for
people to be like that's cool I like
free shots and comedy and it sounds
stupid when you think of it and you just
put it out like I'll just buy everybody
in the crowd a shot and then everyone
will take a shot together and it'll
create just like a nice Icebreaker Vibe
but that's ended up carrying the entire
show for the past three years of this
like ceremony where everyone cheers is
and like you'd be surprised the little
things that kind of make is that at the
beginning of the show or it's awesome I
think but it's not just the shot I think
it's the common experience you know like
I think now with social media and stuff
people want to be a part of something so
that's why when you have those unique
elements to something they want to brag
that they were there that they were a
part of it more so than just like
catching a comedian and then telling
their friends they want to be within the
experience I think yeah what do you guys
think is so like that that's that brings
an interesting point of like trying to
create unique content because now it's
like every comedian has a comedy special
everyone can like post it on YouTube so
like what is the next what do you guys
think is the next and like Ian with your
special like you you did more like a TED
talk so you were looking to kind of play
with the format as well so like what do
you guys think is next of like all right
everyone can create a special now
everyone can post crowdwork Clips like
how can comedians start to separate
themselves again from just everyone can
do the same thing bro if I knew that I'd
be on a
G5 blowing off this interview with me
with me I'm still opening for
people it's just an interesting time of
like there is a lot of saturation of
this it's probably going to involve AI
yeah yeah it was like why not even last
night in the lowkey audience there was
an IT person oh yeah and we asked them
like how's it going and she's like not
good and she said what I said why and
she's like like people are getting laid
off in it because of AI so yeah I I have
a feeling like there's a way you can use
AI to generate more Comedy clips and
push uh your your your profile online
but I just I I haven't figured it out
yet but somebody
will and also with with like Ai and
speaking of like comedy specials I
almost feel like people are going to
start doing more themed specials it's
like you're gonna have like a certain
topic and you're just gonna hammer on
this and I think I heard there was um I
won't like blow up a spot like a ComEd
at the mothership was running his new
hour and it was all based on like one
topic and this was like a very like
famous comedian so I feel like that
maybe the trend is starting to be like
okay instead of just a bunch of joke
joke joke jokes what is like my story
what is the Arc of this one theme that I
want to do I could see it going in that
way as well so people get to know like
people have been doing that though like
Eddie isard true used to I forgot the
name of the special but it was about
like history of the world or something
like that and I saw it it was just like
like a like whatever his version of the
history of the world from one point to a
certain point so you know Comics have
done that but you just have to pick a
topic or a theme that can you can
resonate with like a majority of people
are a good Niche then you're good you
know I I'm curious what do you guys
think about like the crowd workor
specials do you think that people are
going to keep doing that or do is that
kind of the people are talking about do
I don't know I feel like everybody has
it works well I think it get gets people
in the door and then they fall in love
with the axe a lot like I I look at a
lot of this thing from like a marketing
social media brain a little bit of like
as a consumer if I see a good riff I
don't assume like the whole show is Riff
but some people really loved being
ripped apart at comedy shows they
purposely go for it and they're not
being rude or anything but they really
love it and if the audience is there
like there can be just as many crowd
workor specials I think are great like
people I've seen people especially in
Alberta they love to just sit down and
just get roasted wow for full and it's
like you were saying in your English
accent in your perfect English
accent about maybe she's
AI listen oh my God
list I'm not saying she's
not watching him discover bilingualism
is the best thing I've ever seen but you
were talking about people like want a
sense of community and want to be
involved and like being involved in a
clip and that's part of like with Matt
like I feel like some women go to the
show to get his attention first to like
get his attention but then when they see
that he post the clips and they're
involved that makes more people want to
go get go there get involved get a good
seat and he's not he's never like
disrespecting him and it's all good fun
so it's like what I've seen people go on
Jerry Springer to ruin their lives so
why wouldn't you go on and and be in a
comedy click that joy for everybody well
even like rose battle I remember years
ago before the like comedy clip um Jeff
would like in the beginning of the show
have anyone from the audience come and
line up and he'd be like you're ugly
your
shirt and people just it was like I've
never been so embarrassed but this is
the best time of my life like it's not
that part isn't new but I think for a
while people were scared of getting
roasted cuz they were became like a
little bit more sensitive so then they
didn't want to go to comedy shows
anymore like I have friends like don't
send me in the front they're going to
like they panic and now there's like a
new type of crowd work that's not like
you're not going to cry they're just
gonna speak with you and do jokes but I
think we're crowd work maybe is is just
changing it's funny how based on what
you're saying like the world is getting
more sensitive and thick skinned at the
same time yeah yeah that's I was
thinking how that that's so weird cuz
you would think it would just be one way
or the other but there's but I guess
that's how the world is there's people
as thick skinned and then there's people
who are sensitive and can't take a joke
but then there's always going to be the
people that love a good joke on them
like they know what they're walking into
and they do it even if it some of the
views might conflict they're like I know
I'm walking into the show I know I'm
going to be made fun of but I'm going to
have a really good time and wash it off
supposed to sometimes they'll go to a
comedy show and then just get purely
[__] on and they leave being like that's
not what I wanted that's that's not what
these are free tickets I don't know why
they paid me to be
here yeah some people will walk into a
comedy show I can't believe he made me
laugh I'm going to report
this this is not the stand up poetry
slap I thought it was going to be ruined
my Sadness the worst birthday I've ever
had I guess that is paralleled with like
yeah cancel culture and how comedians
can get comedians seem to be at the
Forefront of like oh they said a joke
and it's offensive or whatever but like
are you guys even seeing that in the
industry as a whole is that even like
has that really even been an issue or is
that more of just like headlines blown
out of proportion I feel like
everybody's at the Forefront everybody's
a Target like you know in whatever field
like you know it's it's just that we're
comics and we can talk so we're
definitely like one of the people on in
in the Target but there's other groups
and people in Target of like you know
people just are just waiting by the
keyboard for a slip up you know to put
so that they can get on to be the first
person to call call that person out mhm
yeah it's definitely a scary thing
though to like think about like even
like 10 years in the future like I
better not say something stupid right
now because in 10 years it's GNA bite me
in the ass and somebody's G to try to
cancel me or something it's
like well I'm interested just to jump
back on a little bit because you're
about to record a special what are you
and every comedian's giving away
specials for free now so I feel like
also comedians may start to sell them I
think like I self produced one three
years ago and always sold it on my
website and that was just what I did and
now it's like merch I can sell it shows
and stuff so how are you now that you're
about to film a special how are you
looking at okay this is what has been
working but how can I stay ahead of the
wave again I'm gonna self-release it and
I'm gonna put on this app called mint
comedy so mint comedy they're they're
great they stream shows live at the
seller three nights a week they also do
shows at the comedy store and they also
want they also offered me 100% of
whatever is purchased wow oh nice you
know and and it's like they made that
very clear that they want to support the
artists you know and this is the this I
think is the future you know and it's
like they were very welcoming to me very
open to me they really wanted me to
succeed you know they're also a sponsor
in my special so uh these are the type
people that I want to work with you know
and it's like also I'm talking about a
lot of serious subjects I'm talking
about my mom I'm talking about my family
and I want to be able to own that I
don't want to just give it away to
streaming showers and they own my mom
story you know so it's a part of that
some sensitivities about that as well so
yeah I'm just doing the self-release
route man I think that's the future you
know it's like if you have a large
enough audience and even if you don't
just I think that's the move I I'm not
blinded by I want to be with Netflix I
want to be with HBO or some of these
streaming services which you know
eventually if I do do business with them
awesome but for this specific special my
first one out the gate this is what I
decided to do so sell it instead of
instead of putting it on YouTube yeah
I'm not going to do it on YouTube yeah
interest okay cool yeah I'm just to see
where people are thinking of is is min a
website or is it on YouTube mint's
website mint comedy yeah yeah yeah
because they they live streamed into
movie theaters recently I think yeah a
live thing from the seller and they
streamed in like a bunch of movie
theaters oh yeah they're starting to
like you know so they're and this is
created by someone who's worked very
close in comedy for a while you know he
was a um manager with uh he's da Shell's
manager for years now he manages mammer
then he opened up M comedy and so you
know this guy is you know some I really
trust and love and they're looking after
artists first you know yeah and I I just
did a video essay on JFL and kind of
track the story to how they got to where
they are now and with Howe Mandell
taking over a big thing I've heard him
talk about is like the digital footprint
of JFL and staying relevant and trying
to be more in the Zeitgeist Beyond just
like the few weeks the festival happens
so like what what are you guys trying to
do as like comedies are trying to figure
out social media what is the festival
trying to do to kind of keep up as
well uh I think the first thing we're
trying to do is definitely around new
faces so obviously that's something that
just for laughs has been doing for years
which in the comedy community obviously
everyone knows about it it's such a big
deal and people showcase all over the
world to be part of new faces but the
fans didn't really know about it so
that's kind of our our our first step in
that direction we really want to like
own that online and make sure that
people discover Talent through this
amazing project that we have and uh
otherwise there's different things that
we're we're looking at like for instance
low key um we filmed it together in
Vancouver with Just for Laughs like
we're trying to figure out what's the
best way of of going about it but I
think it you know things are always
changing like every 10 years and I think
if you think of like how we used to
watch shows on television
and then there was a while where we
stopped paying for it and then we just
like find them so those shows like I
always think of like How to Make It in
America should have been like six
seasons but since we're all streaming it
for free they cancelled it and then we
started W getting so much content for
free online but now we people are
willing to pay for a streamer for
Spotify and for this and now I think
it's going to shift again so some people
are posting um their their specials for
free on YouTube but then the true fans
are like no I'm willing to pay just to
to see special and can or subscribe to
his Instagram or only fans or whatever
platform people choose to monetize
because people do want to support so I
think it's just like about adapting to
what's happening and where your
community and fans live pretty much
beautiful okay well speaking speaking of
community um did have a few questions
posted in our Facebook
group um from comedians all over the
world are members in this group and um
one of the questions that came up was
from Michelle vanu H who asked uh was
there a time you wanted to quit comedy
and what kept you moving
forward why' you look at me well you're
the oldest so I thought
that wowow bet you wouldn't say that to
a
woman never ask
her most person you gray hair here I
don't know
what I mean not really yeah I mean there
was a moment when I did kind of slow
down for like five years but I was
writing and I was like thinking more of
like getting into directing but it was
always in Show Business and I knew I
wasn't in love with it as much as my
other friends who were doing like living
in New York City and doing four or five
sets a night but now I just like let me
start back doing like one set a night
and be in love with that until it grew
into like the three four set a night
thing again you know what I mean but I
mean you just it's just like anything
else you're in a relationship with
somebody you might be in more in love
with them at one point than another
point and then get back into it with you
know with them and it's just you just
got to go with the vibe you know you
can't like force it it just drive you
crazy it's fine it's fine if you're not
in an in love with it the way you were
before just relax and it should come
back if it doesn't come back then you're
not doing what you're supposed to be
doing and find the thing that you're in
love with it's all right I did quit I
did I did quit at one point I um my mom
um was a very like heavy drug addict
around the time I was 25 she wased
to oh we're fine we're
fine we're totally fine no but she um
she she had she had a bad back surgery
in 2008 that went wrong and then they
were giving her like oxie like it was
nobody's business so up until the age of
25 I was doing comedy and it was going
great and I was able to get to like
Gotham Comedy Club granted I still
allowed to bring 10 people when I got
like wasn't yeah only they like you can
get three minutes if you bring 10 people
and I had to call all my cousins in the
story i' to be like please pull up um
but it got to a point where like comedy
was going great and I was super happy
but my life at home was absolutely just
this couldn't be what life for 25 yold
looked like so I was like if comedy is
meant to come back to me it will and I
went and I worked at a resort in the
Dominican Republic for four years as
their marketing manager and I where I
created all the content and there was
always a party and we had to party with
the guests and do all that and then Co
hit and I came back and that job ended
up being the inspiration for the
kickback to so you learned so much about
marketing doing that exact comedy but
also greeting people at the door like
one by one cuz that was our job at the
resort we had to know everyone by name
we had we had to know their kids' name
we had to know their sign we had to know
what their favorite way their towels
were pressed and it was kind of like
that customer service aspect that I
think we ended up integrating into the
show to kind of always make people feel
seen at the base of it but I don't think
I would have ever gone there if I didn't
take that step back for myself and be
like who am I as a person not Jenny's
daughter taking care of her every day or
driving this grandparent into the
hospital or stuff like that so like life
does happen sometimes and it's okay to
take a step back to like reflect and fix
figure out what it is you want so I
think sometimes it break is here's
another question from his Comics how's
Jenny
doing Jenny Jenny's killing it now Jenny
lives in Greece with Dad they're loving
it they I miss them haven't seen them in
a while but she's now she's good she's
cleaned CO's over we got her off of it
but she's just like living her best life
in gree now do dope dope very nice qu
even like even you asking a sincere
question sounded sarcastic it was like
amazing wow how dare you yeah
the laugh I meant
it I meant it bro J Jenn Jenn yeah what
about you Paul I I think it's like any
relationship you know where you feel
like the turmoil the ups and downs and
you want to kind of just like you have
moments and thoughts of like stopping
but like it was never enough to where I
ever strongly considered quitting comedy
you know like I also do acting and
writing and directing so those also keep
me busy and ALS so it's like I just want
to create stuff and stand up I can just
leave the house hit a mic and do art so
there's something about the immediacy of
it that I don't think I can ever let go
of because it's so I yeah I just really
never considered ever stopping like that
you know like there's frustrations
obviously and then there's moments where
I'm like man am I like do I suck yeah
should I do something else I think
that's what makes you an actual comic
though if you ever have those questions
of yourself yeah which is normal and
it's so like you're like I mean even the
relationship that I'm in right now like
sometimes we'll have the most amazing
time together and then there's moments
where you have doubt and you're like
this person annoys me so much and then
you yeah love them again I feel that I
just think whatever works for you that
makes you the best performer you can be
is is what you need I I've had times
where I've gotten really down on myself
like why am I not up five days a week
like I'm not a real comedian but I'll
have a great opportunity or the show I
produced goes well but I don't know I
just feel like every comic kind of has
that internal struggle sometimes of like
selfworth or being like is this is this
worth it especially in the first 5 years
you're like what the [__] am I doing and
you book something oh cool yeah you just
keep pushing I've wondered that about
you too it's like why is she not up five
nights a week you know what I'm saying
even though I never met It's actually an
intervention yeah we're all here to say
you guys thanks guys because I'm gonna
go see Jenny
again okay cool and just two more here
the second one here is from Bobby Sutton
what is the best business advice you
have
gotten guess about the comedy business
or we all know the worst advice you've
given Ian but is I'm terrible with
business I need to get better with it to
be honest like I I just dive too much
into like writing and coming up with
jokes and thinking that's going to carry
me and that so you know
just yeah you you're like came from such
a real place yeah so uh yeah man just
look at this as a it's not even
my observation is like you just got to
look at just like in anything whether
it's just whatever you're doing just
trying to get an outside overall
perspective of the whole thing so that
you can see what the business is doing
see what you're doing see where you are
in it and how you can
expand in it the way you
want I actually have like somewhat of
business advice because I used to have
an influencer Market marketing agency
and I would work with Brands like Under
Armour hellofresh like all these
different brands and I'd approach
comedians who do skits and stuff on
their page and say hey this brand would
love to work with you and they would go
I'm not an influencer like really brush
me off you know and I thought that was
really silly because they'll say yes to
a commercial that they didn't write that
an agency wrote and then people remember
them as that character for the rest of
their life you know um I think there's
so much power in being able to approach
friends and you be able to con like
control the narrative and tell the story
and that's something I think that
sometimes comedians judge in content
creators or influencers but that they
get right because in any creative
business at the end of the day the money
comes from advertising so if you're like
before I listened to David Spade uh's
podcast and he was saying you used to
write on SNL to maybe one day book a
commercial now the commercials are like
do want to do a commercial and people
are like I'm too cool for this you know
but I think that if you're able to to
work with brands in a way that they
align well with what you're trying to do
and they're willing to let you control
the narrative and the story then that's
a really good opportunity to kind of try
to create for yourself so nice she's
right I've had bands Brands pay me not
to talk about
them clearly Just For Men was one yeah I
make I make a lot of money my RO aren't
hitting I don't every time I roast you
they take your side it's it's not they
take listen yeah I'm just listen keep
the podcast going I got to use a
bathroom oh yeah you're good yeah we're
on the the last question but yeah Paul
what's the best business advice you uh
someone I mean it's really good advice
actually they said um uh do you know
what you're
selling and I was like yeah I'm a
comedian and they're
like like that's it I was like yeah I
mean I do acting I do standup and I uh
you know U my parents are from Iraq and
I'm this and I'm basically like and then
then it's like oh I didn't put any
thought into this you know so I like put
a lot of thought into what is it that
I'm selling what is if someone goes to
see paulah what is it that they're going
to watch and it's like if you want to
know what it is that I'm selling oh
check out my Instagram check out my
website there's all the info right there
you have my bio you can see the work
that I've done you're going to get an
idea of the vibe that I create you're
going to get an idea of the ideas that I
have and what I want to make and what I
want to uh do so people now know exactly
what they're buying when they buy a
ticket whereas opposed to people buy a
ticket and they don't know what they're
going to go see they're like oh the show
is called uh you know whatever this uh X
whatever the name of the show is and
it's like oh and I don't even know what
to expect it's like is it traditional
lineup is it this like how does it work
is there a website there's no website
for it you know so all the tickets are
only on Eventbrite is there like how are
they integrating this marketing so um
and I think a lot of it is what I
learned from Aron like Aron really
helped me identify what lowkey really is
you know like what the sort of vibe like
I I needed someone to zoom out and sort
of like share that you know so she did
and it gave me so much
perspective and you because before me
and Matt were like we just want to be
funny we're be funny we're just going to
go on stage and be like hey what's up
right and just do crowd work you know
and that's the show but it's like I
don't really have a whole lot of uh
business perspective you know but now I
do what did you figure out with low key
like what was what did you kind of tweak
to
help um I think it's I mean it's funny
because one part was when I went to
Eva's show what I thought was
interesting is that how warm and
welcoming the space was
which lowkey was as well but whenever
you go to a comedy store or comedy bars
in general you walk in the bouncer is
like really mean and sit there and don't
talk and you better buy two drinks and
it was very like stressful you know and
I when I loved about Eva's shows it
feels like I'm part of this I don't feel
ins significant you know and and I was
like okay is there a way that we can
bring that so I think so and that starts
from social media you can like start
creating that so we'd like make sure
because they have some Die Hard fans
who've been going to all the shows so
we'd start like messaging people
individually I helped them out also with
creating ads creating brand identity and
having that conversation of like wait
let's talk about what is special about
low key and what's unique about it and
focus on it because in the beginning
they were focused a lot on how they blew
up in the pandemic and as an audience
member myself I was like I'm so sick of
hearing about the pandemic I want to
pretend never happened so like I don't
don't brand your show about the pandemic
you know I think you guys created
something unique and it would have
worked no matter what of course it
helped but you know so then we're like
what is special about oh anybody can
roll up anything can happen and we kind
of like worked on that all together and
and yeah I think they had created it but
then from an outsider perspective I kind
of like was able to put it into words
maybe yeah yeah real raw off the cuff
yeah yeah yeah love it awesome what
about you yeah well my first piece of
advice if you're producing is don't quit
your day job because well like for for
real like I got to a point where I was
like oh I'm going to you know I'm just
going to do the kickback and put all my
time into the kickback but I would say
that if you're just starting out or if
you're just starting a
show you have to have like a a job
somewhere to help you carry yourself and
then everything that goes into your show
is then put back into your show because
for a while like I was having to live
off my show and it was the most
stressful thing I've ever done it made
me feel terrible yeah I felt like I
couldn't pay people what I wanted to pay
them because I had to survive so I do
think there's a lot of other factors
that you can do to kind of alleviate the
stress if you're like if I'm talking
about producing or whatnot because I've
found in my career that the times where
I'm a little bit off or a little bit
like not really present or my
performances aren't the sharpest or my
production of the show could have been
better are the times where I'm like very
financially stressed so it's uh it's
that and also just like what's your
ethos you know like what's who are like
that's what Isabelle had asked me three
years ago about the kick back when we
were about to get on the festival and
they weren't sure they're like do maybe
we want you maybe we don't and I sat
down with her at a restaurant and she's
like what's your ethos and I was like I
should know it it's a Greek word but I
don't know what you're talking about
right now and she's like so you're what
like you're just someone who goes and
like shakes her like shakes your ass on
stage and gets people all riled up for a
comedy show and I'm like that and but
she's like no like who who are you guys
like if you could sum up your show or
who you are in one sentence like an
elevator pitch that for me has been the
best advice like we're a comedy party
that merges house music and standup
comedy together that's it and like that
for me has kind of been a good a good
way to get started and also having a
brand kit is really important when
you're approaching sponsors and stuff
like that just having your documents
ready at any point if you are trying to
build yourself or a show like have your
stats of your Instagram be able to make
anyone else's job who's looking for you
easy by just having everything ready I
think that's what we learned in
marketing and pitching sponsors and
stuff it's like you have your documents
with your bio like sometimes people
don't want to do that many clicks so you
can have a you can have a link tree you
can have a website you can have all
these things available with 20 links on
Instagram but if you're like a producer
or Booker or someone in business you
already have a million things on your
plate and you want someone who's going
to approach you to make your life easier
easier and come to you with like a like
a proper proposal so that's coming from
the production side for me but that's
been the best advice just be ready and
be prepared and like your documents in
order to be able to send out whenever
whenever you need yeah you're right
people are lazy so do their
work what I'm saying man but they are
though they people are you can't expect
someone to be looking for you nobody is
looking for you nobody is scouring
Montreal for a little brown girl who
throws a comedy party absolutely no one
and I do think that's something people
really need to get out of their system
and and it's okay if it's like an
insecurity but like I had to have that
moment with myself like no one's looking
for me no one no one's like where's
where's the next Mindy King like no
one's looking for me I have to put
myself in front I have to show them why
this is important and I have to show
them why it's going to make money most
importantly hold up are you Indian
angri or just are you just Greek I'm
Greek and Brazilian but people you know
put me in different categories racially
ambiguous but it's no one's looking for
the next SPX for me to check I have to
just be like this is who I am this is
where I'm putting myself in front of and
yeah that's how I feel well I mean in I
I can't than y enough for even taking a
taking your time to do this and take a
chance to just come and sit here and
talk about this I it was it was hard man
holding your pee that long it was very
difficult to I mean it's a I had a lot
of [__] to do Arion had to convince Yan
in English and in French
yeah you know you know so God bless
her you know yeah I really do I mean I
value Comedians and all the work and
sacrifice that goes into it being a
comedian but then also interviewing so
many and anytime I ask especially
something like this coordinating so many
schedules I'm I really want to start
leveling up this show and doing
something special and really making a
bigger impact on Comedy Beyond just like
one-on-one interviews and learning
comedy but really like becoming more of
a taste maker in the industry so I
appreciate you guys really taking the
time to thanks for today and if you guys
want to promote what you have coming up
or your shows and things that we can
just with that well we're going to be in
Vancouver November 3rd for the kickback
and we're going to start our tour so you
guys can stay tuned for that beautiful
where they follow that on kickback.
monreal on Instagram perfect cool yeah I
got uh October 3 at the comedy store in
La I'm running Detroit Player and then
Miami on October 5th and 6th and then
13th and 14th of October Detroit House
of Comedy gonna film the special so if
you're in the Detroit area or
just just fly just fly to Detroit come
through where they follow you at Paul
Leia comedy El L A I forgot most
important part yeah about branding like
what I'm like yeah I
[Laughter]
did uh follow me Arian Tonka I post my
running times on Instagram people are
really into it show off yeah nice yeah
yeah yeah perfect uh follow me on
Instagram and it's probably the same on
Twitter and on uh what's the other thing
that threads at Ian Edwards comic and
you see all my Comedy clips and dates so
just whatever on social media just
follow me there I'm on YouTube too but
beautiful [__] leads to [__] you go to
Instagram it'll take you to everywhere
perfect yeah and and this show is
available on YouTube and all your
favorite podcast apps so go subscribe to
the YouTube channel tell your favorite
comedy friends about hot breath and uh
thank youall for being on the show thank
you having us you yay that's so fun
let's go